rendre sa décision sur l'avenir
institutionnel de l'alsace en octobre
bonjour brigitte klinkert présidente du
conseil départemental du haut rhin avec
fedex berry et votre homologue du
bas-rhin vous avez rencontré la semaine
dernière jacqueline gourault c'est la
madame alsace du gouvernement comment
s'est passé ces entretiens
bah écoutez l'alsace est désormais
inscrite à l'agenda gouvernemental
c'est devenu un sujet national je crois
qu'il faut s'en féliciter
avec frédéric vérine nous avons en effet
rencontré jacqueline gourault mercredi
dernier qu'elle a été missionné par le
1er mai sur le dos yade et j'ai envie de
dire nous sommes entrés dans une étape
ici vive puisque d'ici six semaines si
tout se passe bien nous pouvons signer
l'acte de renaissance de la dass et nous
serons mobilisés d'ici là chaque instant
avec tous les alsaciens qui nous
soutiennent
il ya plusieurs hypothèses sur la table
d'après le préfet rendu par jean luc
marx le gouvernement semble privilégier
la fusion des deux départements alors
que vous vous militiez plutôt pour la
création d'une collectivité unique à
statut particulier
vous seriez prête à faire des
concessions alors déjà je dois dire que
madame gros a été très à l'écouté et qu
elle a reconnu aussi le désir d'alsace
et la vocation transfrontalière unique
du territoire alsacien
nous l'avons dit aussi que notre projet
est beaucoup plus innovant plus celui
d'une simple fusion il s'agit d'un
projet d'une euros collectivités
d'alsace qui forte de nouvelles
compétences aura demain les moyens
d'agir et de réussir pour les jeunes et
pour la france
est-ce que vous pensez que tous les élus
alsaciens vont vous suivre il ya le
maire de colmar gilbert meyer qui a mis
de l'huile sur le feu la semaine
dernière il est favorable à une entité
alsacienne fusion des deux départements
par exemple mais ils posent déjà ces
conditions le siège administratif de la
future collectivité devrait être colmar
on repart comme en 2013 avec la guerre
entre haut-rhinois et bas-rhinois alors
une fusion simple département du pas
envisageable
l'alsace était hier une région le simple
département ne vraiment pas à la hauteur
des enjeux et nous avons besoin de
vraies compétences demain pour redonner
à la stib sa place ici dans le bassin
rhénan sur la prise de position
concernant le siège
ce n'est absolument pas le sujet le
sujet aujourd'hui c'est le retour de
l'alsace avec les compétences qui lui
permettront demain d exploiter tout son
potentiel rhénan est ce qu'elle voit
bien on voit bien en effet les
arrière-pensées qui qu'ils disent à
diriger est-ce que vous pensez que ce
calendrier n'est pas trop serrés 6
semaines écoutez cela fait deux ans au
nom pour ma part depuis que je suis
président du département ce que je me
bats avec frédéric bierry